У далекому 1958-му тут кілька тижнів служив Елвіс Преслі.
Король рок-н-ролу, подейкують, навіть зіграв невеличкий концерт
у місцевому стрипбарі на цьому піаніно.
Американські військові фактично сформували
баварське містечко Графенвер після Другої світової.
У цьому барі чимало постійних відвідувачів -
саме американські солдати з військової бази неподалік.
Ґертруда Ляйато стоїть за цією барною стійкою вже 27 років
і дбає про солдатів, коли вони щасливі, розлючені чи засмучені.
Для тих, хто заходить сюди, це більше, ніж просто бар,
а Ґертруда - більше, ніж просто його власниця.
Вони не називають мене по імені, всі звертаються до мене: мамо.
Багато хто також каже, що це їхній дім далеко від дому.
Іноді виникають проблеми вдома або хтось помирає,
і тоді вони приходять сюди пригнічені,
і коли ти це бачиш, то намагаєшся трохи розрадити.
Я не можу сказати, що це мої діти,
але вони так часто приходять, що це вже моя родина.
Графенвер - тихе містечко, в якому знаходиться
найбільша закордонна база американської армії.
Тут живуть 12 тисяч військових та їхні родини.
Щороку завдяки цій базі економічно слабкий регіон
отримує майже 660 мільйонів євро.
Крім того, майже три тисячі цивільних робочих місць для німців
безпосередньо пов'язані з американською базою.
майже половина загальної кількості населення Графенвера.
Іншої роботи тут не знайти.
За словами мера містечка, для нього можлива втрата прибутків
у разі виведення американських військ - лише частина проблеми.
Ми відзначаємо нині 75 років спільного життя в маленькому містечку
з населенням лише шість з половиною тисяч мешканців.
Весь час це були приємні стосунки, дружні відносини,
і я думаю, що це пішло на користь обом націям,
і ми сподіваємось, що це так і залишиться.
Американські військові не лише забезпечують Графенвер,
а й отримують дещо натомість.
Крістал - одна з постійних відвідувачок цього бару.
Вона родом з Техасу і вже чотири роки у Графенвері не як військова,
а як цивільна співробітниця американської бази.
Вона вважає, що життя тут - унікальний досвід як для неї, так і для солдатів.
Це не просто служба.
Це можливість пізнати іншу культуру всередині країни.
Солдати іноді не бачать нічого іншого, окрім своєї роботи.
Є хороші речі, які вони можуть бачити, але є і погані.
Я думаю, що приїжджаючи до Німеччини, занурюючись в іншу культуру,
вони бачать добро, багато добра.
І іноді це саме те, що потрібно.
У цьому барі сподіваються, що з Графенвера не будуть виведені американські війська,
адже це буде втратою не тільки для міста та його жителів, а й для самих солдатів.
Не такі однозначні настрої в іншій частині Німеччини.
Це містечко Шпангдалем у землі Рейнланд-Пфальц.
Вже понад пів століття тут розташована
одна з найважливіших американських баз у Європі.
Родина Ґюнтера Шнайдера живе тут вже багато поколінь.
Злітно-посадкова смуга - лише за кілька сотень метрів від оселі.
Це те, що нам часто доводиться переживати протягом дня.
Це доволі важко.
Від постійного шуму він хворіє. Три інфаркти.
Як і його сусіди, він вже майже не сподівався, що сюди колись повернеться спокій.
Коли раптом Вашингтон оголосив, що виводить американські війська з Німеччини,
в тому числі і зі Шпангдалема.
Втім, незабаром інша новина: база ніби таки залишається.
Ця військова база - одна з найсучасніших у Європі.
Після повідомлення про те, що звідси виведуть тисячі солдатів,
німецькі політики почали проводити кампанію за збереження бази у Шпангдалемі.
Американці витрачають у цьому регіоні близько 100 мільйонів євро
на послуги, оренду, ресторани, плюс інвестиції, тобто будівельні компанії
та інші бізнеси існують завдяки американцям.
Думки ж місцевих мешканців розділилися.
На мою думку, це недобре, якщо американці підуть.
Взагалі-то американці мають бути в Америці, а не в Німеччині.
Винищувачі F-16 мають перебазувати до Італії,
але більшість співробітників ВПС мають залишитися у Шпангдалемі.
Як це відбуватиметься, військовим не дозволено розповідати.
А от ті, хто у відставці і нині живуть неподалік бази, можуть вільніше говорити.
Річард Лент - один з них. Він не хоче повертатися до Америки.
Він дуже любить старі німецькі мотоцикли і колекціонує їх.
Вони витрачають там в Італії мільйони доларів на нову лікарню,
стоматологічну клініку. Вони побудували нову школу, величезний фітнесцентр.
Я просто не можу уявити, що це все не використовуватимуть.
Фермер Міхаель Біллен це сприймає як політичні ігри.
Він нині став ще й місцевим політиком і лобістом гарних відносин зі США.
Можна покарати Меркель. Можна спробувати шантажувати німецьких політиків,
можна дратувати людей. Але американцям не можна відмовлятися від такої
стратегічно важливої для НАТО позиції.
Тоді ти відмовляєшся від своїх претензій на владу у світі.
Втім, місцеві жителі у Шпангдалемі на вивід військ не мають жодного впливу
навіть якщо саме їм доведеться жити з наслідками політичних рішень.